alors bien évidemment les français ne
sont pour les premiers à avoir ouvert le
dossier les américains les japonais
surtout on ouvert la voie depuis
longtemps regardé la fascination qu'a
exercée sur jean pierre chevènement la
visite d'une cité entièrement vouée à la
science au japon
voici tsukuba la ville du futur nous
sommes au nord-est de tokyo la capitale
depuis une dizaine d'années c'est ici
que s'élabore l'avenir économique
industriel et scientifique du japon
25000 personnes y travaillent en
permanence que ce soit dans
l'électronique la biologie la prévention
des tremblements de terre l'informatique
d'agriculture d'énergie voici par
exemple plus grands bâtiments solaires
d'un nombre trop ami c'est un gymnase
avec les français ont toujours été
fasciné par le japon et ses maîtres le
mois dernier donc ministre de la
recherche physique est sous kouba dans
cet atelier les chercheurs programme des
robots ils leur apprennent à conquérir
le monde industriel a travaillé à la
place des hommes car l'homme au japon va
se consacrer de plus en plus à des
tâches de recherche complet au bo et
feront des travaux pénibles déjà dans
les ateliers tous les quinze jours tout
le monde se réunit pour définir les
améliorations apportées au travail
l'ouvrier comme le technicien le cadre
comme l'ingénieur c'est à cela que jean
pierre chevènement penser en organisant
le collègue de la recherche ce robot qui
va bientôt fabriquer des produits venant
concurrencer les nôtres notre recherche
va passer de 1,8 à deux et demi pour
cent du la production intérieure brute
en 85 au japon il vise déjà les 3% alors
ça vaut le coup de féliciter